derrière cette frontière l'europe
s'arrête
nous sommes au nord de la grèce au mont
athos le vatican des orthodoxes un
territoire de 350 kilomètres carrés au
bord de la mer egée ici les lois
internationales ne s'applique pas le
mont athos est une république
indépendante avec son visa mais aussi sa
poste et même sa propre police et aux
biens la loi grecque n'est plus
appliquée depuis 1926
c'est un état autonome ils ont même leur
propre parlement un état dans l'état
donc uniquement peuplé de moine
orthodoxe grecque bien sûr mais
également en bulgare serbe ou encore
russe plus de trois mille moines au
total qui vivent dans une vingtaine de
monastères dont et speed mais nous un
monastère en rébellion ouverte contre le
reste du monde
[Musique]
nous suivons la religion orthodoxe dans
sa forme la plus pure sans concession
contrairement aux autres monastères
nous refusons tout est de l'union
européenne
cela nous permet de rester indépendant
on ne veut pas non plus mélangés avec
les autres religions
en réalité nous sommes les seuls vrais
chrétiens qui existe et nous l'avons
écrit sur notre drapeau
ce sera à l'orthodoxie ou la mort et
pour pénétrer dans le mont athos les
règles sont très strictes à deux femmes
pas de caméras et des visas distribué au
compte gouttes
exceptionnellement les moines rebelles
nous ont invités à passer quelques jours
dans leur monastère une religion pur
plutôt un discours particulier que l'on
retrouve dans les casses est distribué
sur place
on y explique comment l'homme n'a jamais
marché sur la lune ou encore pourquoi
l'amérique est rongée par le satanisme
des idées d'un autre âge mais des outils
high-tech les moines vivent comme au 19e
siècle mais leur site internet est mis à
jour quotidiennement
on y trouve des appels à la mobilisation
mais également les numéros personnels
d'opposants harcelé une posture
agressive qui trouve des relais à
l'étranger moines les figues mais nous
sont soutenus par des fondamentalistes
orthodoxes grecs ils agissent comme un
lobby en faisant pression sur les
députés du parlement et en finançant le
monastère ce groupe est très puissant il
existe en grèce mais aussi dans d'autres
pays comme les etats-unis où il ya une
importante communauté grecque et ce
lobby n'a pas hésité à faire du mont
athos un asile pour des pèlerins un peu
particulier ce fut le cas par exemple un
temps pour radovan karadic criminels de
guerre serbes finalement arrêté en 2008
et condamné par le tribunal
international de la haye après s'être
caché plusieurs mois dans ce monastère
pour cet avocat de thessalonique la
vraie faille réside dans les critères
d'entrée au moins tu hausse aucune
enquête sur les nouveaux venus et la
nationalité grecque accordé sans
sourcilier dès lors que l'on devient
moine un statut bien pratique pour
devenir moine au mont athos
la principale condition s est d'être
baptisé et de reconnaître l'autorité
religieuse du patriarche orthodoxe
il n'y a pas de vérification
systématique du passé
idéal pour se mettre au vert
commanderait et 35 ans ancien
légionnaire qui travaille depuis six ans
à la maintenance du mont athos
il y a un an il a assisté à
l'arrestation du numéro deux de son
monastère qui avait détourné pas moins
de 10 millions de dollars
un matin la police grecque est venu en
bateau dans le monastère
elle était accompagnée d'interpol pour
arrêter le père sergueï il est reparti
avec les menottes aux poings on a trouvé
25 mille dollars en cash dans sa chambre
c'était amélie qui brille stéphanois qui
est quelque temps après on a appris
qu'il avait été arrêté car il faisait du
business avec les états unis
il est attaqué des hôpitaux il y avait
des millions de dollars sur un compte là
bas ils nous avaient dit que dans son
ancienne ville était producteur à
hollywood et qu'il avait voulu quitter
ce monde là mais en réalité il se
servait du monastère comme d'un endroit
pour se cacher cela faisait cinq ans
qu'il était là trafics en tous genres
planque détournement de fonds seuls
quelques affaires ont éclaté au grand
jour ces dernières années au mont athos
le vatican des orthodoxes a toujours su
préserver son image celle d'un musée à
ciel ouvert élevé au rang de patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité par l'unesco
[Musique]
contrairement au mont athos le monastère
de vàd landes en thaïlande n'a rien à
cacher ici pas de secrets de trafic de
ville un dossier et comme chaque matin
le vénérable fera bon moment l'un des 25
moines qui vivent ici se lève
paisiblement
ils partagent l'avis des 15 bronze
pensionnaires des lieux qui préparent
leur nouvelle journée mais elle
s'annonce bien différente de celle des
hommes du dieu bouddha car leur dieu à
eux s'appelle - taille la boxe
thaïlandaise sefra bumba qui les
hébergent ici la boxe thaï c'est sa
deuxième passion après dieu chaque jour
à l'heure où ses protégés commencent
leur footing travaux ma part faire sa
tournée du village en quête de
nourriture
c'est que parmi les 227 lois qui
régissent la vie des bombes il en est
une qui leur interdit tout travail le
bon soin donc quotidiennement compter
sur la générosité des habitants du
village voisin de bang pa kong qui lui
font gentiment l'aumône
8 heures l'entraînement commence le plus
jeune a 10 ans le plus vieux 23 les
quinze apprentis boxeurs suivent un
régime austère à l'image de celui des
bonzes deux entraînements intensifs de
trois heures chacun sous l'oeil expert
de fra bumba mais la religion et la boxe
ne font pas aisément bon ménage et le
bronze pour contourner cette
contradiction se tient une distance
respectable du ring une petite astuce
qui lui permettent d'observer ses élèves
depuis 15 ans fera de ma forme des
boxeurs talent et d'expérience
il sait reconnaître les qualités qui
feront d'un apprenti un champion il faut
être loyal passion j'ai résistons
damiette d'abord lui est déjà champion
son surnom en dit d'ailleurs assez
longtemps de faire il est la fierté de
goma qui le suit depuis dix ans c'est
moi qui les forme et je lui appris à
rester dans le droit chemin
fidèle à l'esprit de la boxe et à la
doctrine bouddhique
je
à 23 ans en de fer est déjà classé parmi
les meilleurs boxeurs de sa catégorie
conséquence à l'école l'entraînement
s'organise autour de lui en fonction de
ses besoins et les apprentis se relaie
pour encaisser les coups sans de fer est
en quelque sorte l'enfant spirituel de
bulma le bonze en effet exige de ses
boxeurs le même engagement la même
discipline que lui-même vis-à-vis de
bouddha et comme il ne peut pas monter
sur le ring
ils forment ces boxeurs à la voie au
rythme de ses encouragements
dans la région tout le monde connaît
bomba évidemment son ring planté dans un
coin du monastère étonne et trouble même
parfois la conscience des bouddhistes
plus rigoriste qui oublie un peu vite
que le bomber boxer ne fait que
reprendre une tradition délaissé depuis
des siècles
cette époque lointaine où les arts
martiaux étaient enseignées par les
moines
avant d'être adulte chaque taille doit
passer au moins quelques jours au
monastère pour l'occasion il se fait
bonzes et se purifie ainsi de ses péchés
de jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
ce soir le nouvel espoir de fra bouma
disputent un match important à bangkok
son surnom petit tigre d'or il a dû
partir tôt ce matin du monastère pour un
autre rituel la traditionnelle séance de
peser pour lui le combat est d'autant
plus important qu'il affronte ce soir
son adversaire sur l'un des principaux
ring de la ville on attend 20 mille
personnes et la télévision doit même
retransmettre ce match en direct fera
boma lui n'est pas venu en tant que
bombes il n'a pas le droit de pénétrer
dans une salle de boxe mais à l'heure du
match
petit tigre d'or c'est que son maître
est avec lui là bas au monastère travaux
ma ne perd pas une minute du combat
[Musique]
et pour ceux qui ont choisi de suivre le
bonze l'espoir c'est d'être un jour à la
télévision à la place de petit tigre
d'or l'espoir d'être à leur tour comme
lui a tendu à l'entrée de la pagode par
le m